[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight 30 years goes pretty fast 30
years ago was the fall of 1989 believe
it or not seems like yesterday and at
the time if you can remember that far
back America seemed unbeatable our chief
rival the Soviet Union had just
collapsed our economy and military
strength dwarfed those of every nation
on the planet America in 1989 was the
uncontested leader of the world free and
otherwise but his three decades later
that advantage has evaporated completely
instead of expanding and solidifying our
power we've wasted it and as a result
we're now in the race of our lives
against a country that in 1989 was so
poor that many of its people could not
afford meat or electricity China and at
this rate China will beat us so the
question is how did America fall so far
so fast and the answer is simple bad
leadership the people who benefited the
most from this country cared about it
the least they were also the quickest to
sell it out to foreign powers for profit
that's obvious now thanks to people like
LeBron James James of course is one of
the most famous athletes in history but
he started off at the very bottom he was
born to an impoverished 16 year old
mother in Akron Ohio he never went to
college and yet thanks to hard work and
remarkable skill James's endorsement
income alone now exceeds 50 million
dollars a year if there's anyone whose
life is a tribute to America to its
decency to its endless opportunity its
LeBron James in return he showers
America with contempt
just yesterday James was asked to
comment on the NBA executive who issued
a one-line statement in support of
democracy in Hong Kong here's how LeBron
James responded I don't want to get into
a war word or sentence feud with Darrell
but Daryl Morey but I believe he wasn't
educated on the situation at hand
and any spoke and that so many people
could have been harmed not only
financially but physically emotionally
spiritually so just be careful what we
what we tweet and we say and what we do
even though yes we do have freedom of
speech but there can be a lot of
negative that comes with that too so
freedom of speech is just fine says
LeBron James as long as you don't do
anything crazy with it like I don't know
obliquely criticize the Chinese
Communist Party who that's out of bounds
it might harm people spiritually it also
might potentially make LeBron James
slightly less rich and of course that's
the real problem with it I think we're
being unfair think that's an unfair
interpretation of what you just saw well
according to ESPN LeBron James has been
adamant in his defense of Chinese
fascism even off camera watch this
Adam Silver got up and addressed the
players and LeBron James one of the
players who got up and spoke and said
hey what are we doing here daryl morey
made these statements you know damn well
if a player made the same similar
statements and cause such war
ramifications for the league there'd be
some sort of league recourse there were
repercussions that the player at the
paid you know potentially this tweet
could cost the NBA hundreds of millions
of dollars which could come out of the
players pockets and so that's the double
standard that was being addressed in
that meeting in other words any American
who questions China ought to be punished
that's LeBron James's view that's what
he's demanding in fact the Chinese
Politburo must not be criticized and yet
there's a very different standard that
James holds for his own country and his
own president watch this they just kind
of used sport to kind of divide us I
would ever sit across from him he would
never even want to talk to him
nothing across virag dough that's the
American president he's talking to you
well if you read James's Twitter feed
you won't be surprised to learn anew
this quote injustice anywhere is a
threat to justice everywhere he tweeted
once our lives begin to end the day we
become silent about things that matter
okay well obviously things that matter
does not include throwing Muslims and
concentration camps in China or the
oppression of more than a billion people
in China so what does matter to LeBron
James and his friends in our ruling
class well the first thing they care
about is popularity and that's why
they're delighted to weigh in
politically when it's fashionable in
West Los Angeles bashing the
administration or protesting the
national anthem or retweeting in support
of transgender rights or whatever their
friends call them brave when they do
this which is one indication it's not
bravery its conformity which is the
opposite usually the other thing that
James and the rest care about of course
is money when you criticize Beijing it
might cost you money here's a perfect
example LeBron James is both starring in
and producing an upcoming film called
Space Jam 2 movies expected to do big
business in China if it's released there
and James can't risk that the rest of
Hollywood made the same decision many
years ago used to see occasionally
movies that criticized the dictatorship
of China or took the side of Tibet
remember Richard Gere whatever happened
to him not anymore in fact that's
unimaginable you can't imagine a major
Hollywood picture taking the side of
Tibet or Hong Kong or the Dali Lama or
human rights in China the world's
largest country no instead Studios now
grovel for Chinese funding and if China
appears in films at all it's always any
positive portrayal meanwhile Russia
which is a completely irrelevant country
most of the time is subverting our
democracy that's what they tell us this
is what corruption looks like